They're waiting to be explored.
My favorite things,
I'm very.
They aren't really favorite themes.
They sort of compulsive themes.
Last year I think obviously a lot about
global warming.
Anybody who thinks thinks about global
warming.
Um,
last year I found that every poem that I
started to write turned out to be a
pound for garb about global warming and
that was not a healthy situation.
I realized I could only write about
that,
so I had to forcibly move myself away
from that theme back to other themes.
Each poem has an essence of colonel,
every work of art as Peter Brook,
the Great Theater director pointed that
out,
that you can reduce any work of art to
one kernel of force of colon
inspiration.
And if every poem is trying to use that
same kernel,
then you're going to become repetitive
and become dull.